[Musique]
Véronique prince Hélène buzetti
Christian Dufour bonsoir bonsoir
je sais pas si vous avez suivi
aujourd'hui
le choix de Jérémy Hansen mais
la poursuite de la recherche le retour
Artémis après Apollo
vous avez bon on va Véronique vous étiez
pas né vous mais
Hélène Guinga guerre plus mais bon
[Rires]
ça fait encore de table quand même
Christian je commence avec vous
ça me rappelle mon père en fait qui se
lever très tôt le matin à l'époque à 5h
du matin pour suivre en fait les
premiers lancements de fusil lui en tout
cas ça le faisait rêver moi je dois dire
que je suis un peu plus basé c'est pas
une question d'âge bon Hélène mais le
Canada
lui il était à son apogée là aujourd'hui
très content le rôle du Canada est quand
même important on met beaucoup de sous
là-dedans oui
le dernier budget il y a à peu près deux
points 4 milliards de dollars métallis
sur 14 ans mais quand même pour le
projet lunaire là il y a quelques
milliards prévus là-dedans écoutez je
suis vraiment pas spécialiste de ces
simplement moi personnellement je non ça
ne me fait pas rêver pour répondre à
votre question et je me demande surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on en tire est-ce que
vraiment des applications scientifiques
après qu'on en retire peut-être
peut-être que je suis dans l'ignorance
totale mais je m'interroge est-ce qu'on
pose un regard critique sur ces missions
sur ce qu'elle nous coûte versus ce
qu'elle nous rapporte je sais pas si on
fait pousser des laitue dans de la
Glacière une avancée certaine Véronique
Véronique un petit mot là-dessus
moi ça me fascine quand même
honnêtement je vais même en parler à ma
fille ce soir parce que ma fille de 7
ans aussi est fascinée par l'émission
puis tout ce qui est tout ce qui entoure
le milieu des astronautes et tout ça
alors moi je pense qu'il y a un petit
peu quelques quelque chose en nous le
petit garçon la petite fille qui trouve
ça impressionnant quand même c'est le
produit qu'on voit le Hansen et le
premier Canadien qui va sortir de leur
terrestre quand même et qui va
aller jusqu'à la lune aucun autre
canadien aucun autre astronaute
américain n'avait fait ça jusqu'ici ok
je ferme la parenthèse
Donald Trump
on le sent que ça vous fait rêver c'est
bien j'aime les sports j'aime la
recherche spatiale moi ça m'aide oui
effectivement ça me fait rêver un peu
l'infini grand tout ça ça bon Christian
je recommence avec vous sur Trump demain
il sera accusé on a vu ces images déjà
surréalistes là il est escorté par les
services secrets qu'est-ce que jusqu'ici
là qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire c'est
le début d'un long processus
c'est quelque chose d'un peu historique
c'est une première je trouve qu'on est
dans l'inconnu en fait parce que c'est
difficile de savoir chez quel point
Donald Trump peut être capable de
retourner la situation en sa faveur
parce que des fois jouer les victimes ça
lui allait bien pourtant moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le THC le phénomène
politique Donald Trump est encore
puissant ou pas comment l'opinion
publique doit réagir je te dis une chose
qui peut jouer en faveur en guillemets
de Donald Trump c'était des accusations
qui étaient liées par exemple aux
évènements du Capitole qui ont vraiment
été une attaque contre la démocratie
américaine je trouve que ce serait plus
clair là c'est quand même quelque chose
de compliqué lié à une star du porno ça
remonte à 20 ans donc ça il peut jouer
là-dessus en disant c'est de la
persécution monéga détournement Hélène
de de fonds électoraux et parce qu'on a
falsifié des documents puis qu'on aurait
mis ça à l'abri c'est par là mais il y a
des grands dans l'histoire du crime qui
ont péché et qui ont été attrapés pour
des broutilles aussi Hélène il faut voir
bien sûr comme je disais al
pour évasion fiscale dans le cas qui
nous occupe écoutez bien sûr qu'on
falsifie les documents puisque le but du
paiement c'était de faire taire cette
dame pour que cette relation ne surface
pas surface pendant la campagne
électorale alors ça a été étonnant qui a
écrit dans leur document de dépense
électorale pour de 20 pour faire taire
une prostituée vous voyez alors je suis
un peu moi je m'inquiète par tout ça
parce que comme le disait Christian il y
a un état d'esprit aux États-Unis
extrêmement polarisé et et je pense que
ça pourrait venir alimenter ce sentiment
de persécution je pense que il y a
plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles on
pourrait vouloir mettre hors des tonnes
nuire monsieur Trump on devrait vouloir
le mettre hors des tas de nuire il s'est
montré pas du tout à la hauteur des
responsabilités qu'il a occupé je pense
à des accusations qu'on va peut-être
voir venir plus tard comme la corruption
d'agents électoral ou comme le dit
Christian incitation à l'insurrection ça
me semble-t-il ça toucherait plus à sa
fonction politique là je crains que ça
ne fasse juste alimenter le personnage
et que au contraire ça facilite
peut-être son retour oui Véronique je
vais aller dans le même sens que là
parce qu'en fait toute la journée en
toute candeur moi je me suis posé la
question sur ces images là qu'on voyait
dans les médias américains cette espèce
de cirque médiatique avec le convoi que
suivant l'hélicoptère et qui filmait la
voiture de Donald Trump se rendre à
l'aéroport puis après ça à New York ça
fait une file de vente de médias je te
demande devant la Trump Tower puis je me
dis ça il carbure à cette publicité là
parce que je veux pas salut en donne
donc ça ça polarise comme disait Hélène
encore plus mais d'un autre côté c'est
plus grand que nature ce qui est en
train de se passer là c'est un moment
historique c'est sans précédent chez un
ancien président des États-Unis qui veut
revenir d'ailleurs comme président et je
me dis ça fait partie quand même du rôle
des médias d'expliquer ce qui est en
train de se passer donc je suis très
déchiré en fait entre cette espèce de
cirque médiatique et la nécessité aussi
de le montrer puis d'en parler pour ceux
qui font des bons invités il faut
expliquer réexpliquer réexpliquer parce
que comme vous dites on peut pas on peut
pas chasser ces images là du de la place
publique là il faut les expliquer par
exemple très bien
hier je sais pas si vous avez vu
monsieur Trudeau il était à Tout le
monde en parle il a reparlé l'État en
Abitibi aujourd'hui et sur l'accès aux
soins dentaires qui est peut-être la
prochaine bataille Québec Ottawa qui se
dessine je fais entendre monsieur
Trudeau la semaine dernière Monsieur
Girard le ministre des Finances du
Québec a dit nous pour ce programme
dentaire annoncé par le fédéral on a
mieux l'argent qu'on va garder le nôtre
qui est peut-être moins généreux mais
qu'on peut se payer on écoute tout ça
qu'on revient
si les provinces veulent travailler avec
nous pour livrer chez eux on va être là
pour ces conversations là mais écoute
c'est pas une chicane là on est là pour
s'assurer que les Québécois comme tous
les Canadiens est accès à des soins
dentaires
on injecte des sommes supplémentaires
pour les soins dentaires et certainement
notre préférence ça aurait été des
sommes additionnels en santé le Québec a
déjà un programme de soins dentaires que
nous finançons alors nous allons
demander un retrait avec une
compensation
il est temps qu'on comme j'ai dit hier
soir il est temps qu'on arrête de
pouvoir évaluer c'est quoi le salaire
des parents selon la qualité du sourire
de l'enfant
tant qu'on arrête dans ce pays de voir
avec le sourire des enfants le salaire
des parents
je vous montre un tableau très très
rapide ça c'est le programme à venir et
remplace pour le fédéral mineur est né
personne handicapées 2025 toute la
population c'est revenu inférieur à 90
000 ça c'est la croix NPD et juste le
Québécois donc parce que au Québec il y
a ces 10 ans et moins et aussi les
personnes qui sont sur l'aide sociale
mais c'est les design moins donc
programme fédéral est plus large et plus
les années vont avancer Hélène sera de
plus en plus large alors comment vous
voyez ce dessiner les prochains mois
là-dessus ouais monsieur Trudeau a beau
dire qu'il ne veut pas de la chicane il
risque de se retrouver avec une entre
certainement une bataille sur les bras
avec Québec parce que ce genre de
négociation le demander le droit de
retrait avec compensation ce n'est
jamais facile je pense là la dernière
fois le prolongement congé parental qui
avait annoncé Ottawa de six mois à un an
Québec voulait créer son propre
programme écouter ça avait pris
quasiment huit ans avant que les deux
ordres de gouvernement s'entendent sur
la somme à transférer le programme du
Québec là dont vous parliez c'est à peu
près 174 millions de dollars par année
la peur québécoise du programme fédéral
prévu ça serait à peu près là grosso
modo un milliard alors vous voyez
beaucoup plus large voilà alors Québec
ce qu'on me dit en couler son épaule
nécessairement opposé à l'idée de
d'élargir notre programme sont soit plus
d'argent mais voyez ça va dépendre quels
sont les priorités
Ottawa va vouloir s'assurer que ces
priorités à lui sont aussi couvertes et
il y a aussi j'ajouterai il y a un
risque si Québec se retire et finance
lui-même avec l'argent d'Ottawa le
programme admettons que les
conservateurs arrivent au pouvoir
monsieur Poirier va pas voulu s'engager
à garder ça en place et là admettons qui
coupe les vivres et ben là Québec serait
comme lui pris avec la responsabilité
d'expliquer à la population qu'il arrête
ce système ou alors continue à le faire
et doit désormais le payer de sa poche
alors il y a quand même un risque de
faire cavalier seul du côté du Québec
oui Véronique hier monsieur Trudeau hier
soir et ce matin a été très clair on
voit que en passant sur n'était pas dans
le programme des libéraux mais
maintenant qu'il a adopté pour faire ce
mariage avec le NPD il y croit de plus
en plus alors hier là on voyait la qui
reculait absolument pas et quand on ne
sait pas que c'est en lien avec
l'entente avec la NPD on a presque
l'impression que c'est ce qu'il est en
train de mettre en place que c'est son
programme les entraînes s'approprier
effectivement que c'est son idée alors
que en réalité ça fait partie de
l'entente avec le NPD moi mes sources à
Québec me disent il y a un bout de
chemin qui aura pas vraiment de problème
à faire de notre côté c'est à dire
qu'actuellement notre programme permet
la gratuité des services pour les
enfants de moins de 10 ans le vous
l'avez montré que du côté du fédéral on
veut faire ça en trois étapes les cousin
et moins après ça les 18 ans est née
personne avec handicap il y a un
troisième étape toutes les personnes qui
ont pas d'assurance par exemple bon
alors du côté de Québec on dit s'il veut
qu'on permette aux enfants de 12 ans et
moins plutôt que 10 ans et moins ce sera
pas tellement compliqué à mettre en
place là c'est pas ça qui venait
seulement écouter le plus cher par
contre les étapes 2 et 3 pour l'élargir
encore plus là attendez un instant
premièrement ce que mes sources à Québec
disent c'est est-ce que vraiment ça va
se concrétiser parce qu'il va avoir le
temps de faire ça d'ici 2025 ou avant on
en doute là du côté de Québec donc en
attendant ce qu'il demande c'est d'avoir
ce financement là
Christian
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cette
joute qui commence il y a bel et bien
une chose quand même
je pense qu'avec un conflit
constitutionnel qui s'annonce importante
ce qui manque c'est Monsieur Jacques
Médecin en fait qui doit être là qui
devrait être là avec Monsieur Trudeau
pour parler parce que dans des dossiers
comme ça on voit qu'on est des facto
face à un gouvernement de coalition
l'idéal néo-démocrate or les démocrates
sont extrêmement centralisateurs il
s'occupent pas vraiment du fédéralisme
qui sont très très dépensés rappelons
qu'il n'y a pas juste le Québec en fait
que en partie ce domaine-là dans toutes
les provinces il y a des programmes de
soi-dentaires avec des différences pour
les jeunes ou les les gens défavorisés
et le général de faire embarquer
là-dedans c'est très démagogues ce que
dit Monsieur Trudeau quand tu parlais du
sourire des enfants qu'on va reconnaître
moi j'ose pas venu en fait j'aime pas la
démagogie les provinces sont là on est
dans un système fédéral cette compétence
province qu'est-ce que le fédéral vient
faire là-dedans au-delà du fait qu'ils
veulent se maintenir au pouvoir avec
l'appui d'une ce gouvernement là
est plus à gauche que les gouvernement
libéraux traditionnels à cause
en fait qui donne le temps donc moi ça
m'étonne pas qu'un conflit important de
notre collègue monsieur Auger hier dans
la presse très intéressant qui rappelait
les tonnelles ils aboutissants là-dedans
le problème c'est que on dirait qu'au
Canada il y a de moins en moins de juin
qui comprennent ce que c'est un système
solaire que les promesses sont
souveraines dans leur champ de
compétences elles font les choses à leur
façon et même si c'est pas uniforme dans
tout le Canada c'est pas un problème
mais je me répète qu'est-ce que le
fédéral vient faire là-dedans au-delà du
fait qu'ils veulent plaire au NPD
vendredi on était on décrivait ce drame
à quoi ça ce n'est 8 personnes mortes et
pendant ce temps-là plus tard on
apprenait un compromis sur le projet de
loi sur les langues officielles Hélène à
Ottawa le Québec se disait même content
de ce compromis l'élargissement aux
entreprises à chaque fédéral au Québec
où on en est la c'est réglé
c'est ce qui semble être le cas c'est
sorti de comité donc il suffit juste
enfin une dernière étape à la Chambre
des communes un dernier vote par tous
les partis mais selon ce qu'on comprend
les parties qui rechignaient jusqu'à
présent conservateur et bloqué sera
lirait au gouvernement libéral la raison
est simple pourquoi s'opposer à quelque
chose que même Québec applaudit sa
placerait le Bloc québécois dans une
position vraiment inconfortable
Ottawa les libéraux nous disent depuis
le début on n'a jamais voulu créer un
régime ou notre régime fédéral serait
moins contraignant que le Régime
québécois on cherchait à ce que ce soit
équivalent c'était ça notre objectif
quand on avait déposé notre projet de
loi Québec n'avait pas encore son projet
de loi 96 donc il a fallu s’arrimer mais
on a toujours eu cette intention et donc
on a tout simplement brancher du
résultat dans les faits là je vous donne
20 secondes ça va changer quoi
ça va changer
concrètement là c'est appliqué un peu le
concept de la loi 101 aux entreprises à
chaque fédéral par exemple mais aussi ça
s'applique pas juste au Québec mais ça
s'applique aux francophones au Québec
dans des zones qui seront désignées plus
tard par voie de règlement là où il y a
une un nombre significatif de
francophones
ouais ben je suis tout un contrat avec
le dossier des soins dentaires parce que
sinon dans ce dossier là c'est très
positif c'est entente là entre Québec et
Ottawa il me semble historique en fait
parce qu'un changement vraiment
d'approche au niveau fédéral on accepte
dans les fêtes que la loi 101 même si
c'est pas formellement ça s'applique aux
entreprises fédérales même le CN est
embarqué dans le cuir Canada étant
embarqué dans le coup bravo et cette
victoire là d'autant plus intéressante
que ça n'a pas été facile parce qu'on
sait qu'une partie des libéraux à Ottawa
qui était contre ceux qui ont essayé de
couler le projet parce que était collé
aux embouts québécois ce qui reste
maintenant jusqu'à quel point le
gouvernement fédéral va l'appliquer
parce qu'on sait qu'ils sont pas
toujours très efficaces dans
l'application de leurs affaires pensez
au passeport à tout le reste parce que
les francophones individuellement pour
soutenir debout puis vont parler
français parce qu'ils sont bien habitués
à parler anglais des entreprises
solaires Véronique conclusion là-dessus
mais tout juste avant que ça franchisse
l'étape du comité parlementaire
Jean-François Robert je ministre à
Québec qui est responsable dossier de la
Charte de la langue française et Ginette
petit la ministre fédérale dans le
dossier c'était rencontré ils avaient un
document de travail et finalement ce
qu'on a retrouvé c'est tout ce qu'il y
avait dans le document de travail on
fait pas référence à la Charte de la
langue française mais tous les éléments
sont dans ces 13 alors c'est clair que
Québec est content de ce côté-là et on
se dit mais les entreprises vont avoir
le choix de se plier à la loi fédérale
qui va être très strict ou la loi
provinciale qui prévoit un
accompagnement pour un plan de français
alors on se dit c'est sûr qu'ils vont
adhérer à la loi provinciale à ce
moment-là donc tout le monde est content
on le rappelle quand même mal parti
c'est mieux arrivé merci Véronique
Hélène et Christian à très bientôt au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI